yeah welcome to this video it took a
long while to get this game style and it
is a huge rating gap yeah people
recently asked them why are the
opponents so no rated in 15 minutes yeah
time some they are they're relatively
few players in this pool of players to
be paired and it seems that once in a
while is unavoidable to have those so
those big gaps of course I'd like to
have a slightly more even game but yeah
anyway you need to play those games as
well and once in a while is really gets
to instructive positions ok we have them
started out as somesh Kings Indian and
now which was posted to vanoni kind of
position he hasn't played e6 yet
transferred the night to c7 and prepares
b5 girl you should prevent be fire for
the time being over this interesting no
he closes the position hmm
okay at least them my night is already
on g 3 which means i cannot play G for
the best move here ok not permitted by
words would be g2 to g4 hopping over the
night and then h4 h5 attacking on the
King side but now it is blocked all
right I don't want to take only 6 cm so
usually not very helpful for white you
expose your default square to a nice
1964 for example hmm interesting yeah
probably I must complete them
development at some point if he goes 98
f 5 always have the capture and F form
it's not it's not a big deal I think hmm
dad this was this wasn't the most
precise smooth and I should have played
h5 there a five h5 not h5 it's not
possible f5 would have been I would have
been probably good damn taking the
chance to to fix the pods here if he
goes f5 I can take a player for this is
quite ok
Wow giving away two moves okay now now
before immediately comes to mind you
know I should I should take this chance
as long as it presents itself it takes
Knight a form and then queen yep not a
for this is very nice now i cannot move
the beep on never ever and i have Knight
b6 and i have queen bee three two before
this is the the toughest thing maybe you
could be one ok is preparing now and
five after all it could also played c5 I
mean it's a very nice position already
ok but let's let's go here we place at
five I can really take and play a form
rook b12 before it's not too bad getting
the pawn back with the rook on before
he was ready at five to a forum not not
much choice hmm not sure ma'am let's
just take this
I could have taken that five of course
came
and it's just that's just castle
I hardly can play without castling so
let's um let's do that so the next step
to make headway here c4 c5 c5 Knight b6
c4
see 5 9 p-6 z4root p6 something like
that need to increase the pressure let's
also nightie for coming at the end the
deep one is the the winner now another
issue of course is that like it's so
tight down here it's hard for him to to
lose and quite often this will lead to
further problems that like is actually
under too much pressure to to defend it
so c5 now
uh 94-94 this also Knight f6
this one yeah everything's good but this
is this is this is good the night is not
doing much on g3 end
what what would see supposed to play
maybe Knight f6
not very hard to to make any moves maybe
the Bishop f5 I'd just take it not very
attractive but what can you do
yeah it's very passive he lost many many
moves stuff like night here and Knight
f6 it's it's not terrible tolerable f5
he is a player 5 invested more time so
we play that fire by now it's already
almost decisive on the queenside yeah I
wasn't sure Bishop g5 I know I don't
want irie don't want to exchange what if
I just take it around the bishop will
take okay let's improve this bishop get
it to reform
hmm yeah you should just take your form
yeah okay black needs to try exchanged a
couple of pieces to to get some pressure
off this position nope not to have six
or so good plan okay so see 5 or not hmm
I can maybe take a plane 96 fairly solid
mate f6 moon okay let's um prepare look
everyone
increasing the pressure on the b7 poem
on T returns yeah
hmm I should have just take it on on c8
the night on b6 is really am it's a very
nice-looking piece but it does the text
so much make a play Bishop f5 corn let's
let's just take it that simple chess and
rope be one
like rugby one look to be 65 whitestone
escopeta this position on edge and ce4
ce5 is really a move that black cannot
prevent I can play it down followed by
the LD txt from and then d6 we should be
5 activating this Bishop only form so
just here now Knight f6 I can just take
it out of d 6
ok it's not waste too much time I need
to get a TM
your first reaction is c6 and it's
probably good yeah yeah come on this
must be good
pounds on b6 and c6 yeah this is really
a lot I mean if you have those kind of
poles your position usually is very good
even if you have sacrificed substantial
material those kind of pawns are very
strong and i only have sect an exchange
okay we cannot take on c6 this is
immediately as an immediate disaster the
question is how do I proceed now I can
always place his seven but maybe it is
better to think about improving some
pieces
the bishop on the form
would be excellent if it would but
somehow get to the h3 see a diagonal
okay let's let's first play this and
lend support to the sea pawn to encase
it in advance of c7 that it is protected
if you play something like a five I can
none I can go win this pawn but for
Queen B 5 through k1 and i also should
think about bring the h porn at some
point introducing h4 h5 for example it
giving the king of square on each tooth
can be useful yeah okay this exchange
sag wasn't really a natural state oops I
didn't meant to do that just open my
bottle here it wasn't German necessary
strictly speaking but leading to a very
good good position yeah what should he
do
yeah maybe still Knight f6
yeah the problem from White's point of
view in this position is it looks very
attractive but how do you actually
promote the pawns I really don't know
maybe I need to reroute this bishop em2
to be for attacking the deep on on e3 it
is mostly covering b6 which is not bad
but v6 is not attacked at the moment so
it's not clear that this is such a
useful role taking the deformed alyssa
is quite something with bishop before
taking the depot
mmm Kim
I don't know I probably if i'm lucky i
probably just take you from i'd hope
that simplifications somehow help me if
it takes on e4 i will take with the pawn
further supporting the pawn chain and
and keeping it done nicely tied together
this position Queenie filonov a BLEVE
queen at five not shown and yeah but
this is just giving away g67 so almost
seems like he attended that but it's
really terrible I get the bishop 36 also
and the bishop on f5 I already mentioned
before that I'd love to have the bishop
on this diagonal aunty just lifted that
to me this mostly controls the c8 square
so that c7 c8 is some so almost a
decisive
thing okay let's arrest this this rook
even more where it is virtually don't
know
no Bishop g5 setting up this awkward
very awkward pin
I have enough time to prepare this all
probably c7 c8 so we'll see 70 m at this
threatens c8
yeah so check on d5 check a dub will
promote the porn black resigns
yeah the interesting thing here is here
I I this is not precise I should play a
five and the the thing to remember from
this game I mean ninety seven and nine
f6 back obviously isn't great but this
kind of stuff is something that you need
to have in you are let's say positional
repertoire how to play on the queenside
a5 keeps the beep on fixed on b7 it
cannot move oops should really read it
read it cannot it cannot move because
there's always this discover and he has
the pieces set up in the way that he
cannot really prevent before and after
this this is the long-term move this is
an idea and you will never ever get rid
of those weaknesses p 796 and with rook
be one before or something like this you
always get this pawn back and at the end
have a winning position on the queenside
probably instead of e five here black
should go e6 and transpose into a modern
benoni like e6 and take yeah thanks for
watching